hey hey everybody can you hear the beat
and can you feel the heat
hey everybody hear that I gotta start
over baby I wrote a song hey hey hey hey
everybody gonna hear the beat everybody
can feel the heat
everybody heat baby love you can't hear
the heat all right I'm we didn't want me
to introduce you tonight starting over
do it again I would have yeah yeah I'm
starting over now yeah because well you
[ __ ] up twice oh because they're
laughing all right who wants cleaning
hey hey hey hey hey hey everybody
everybody did you feel the heat
hey everybody can you hear the beat
everybody can you feel the heat hey
Wolfgang Amadeus
snippety-snip kool Kat snap everybody
what we got here is going on here is um
we got kalila cool my girlfriend yes
gonna snap that we got jungle jungle
monkey we go why why you while doing the
whoever that guy and then we have a
special guest tonight and I want to get
serious for a second um I love this man
so much
he's on fire right now not because he
has red hair this is look everybody but
my everybody can you feel that he
everybody can you feel the heat
that's a hat thank you thank you so much
we have Andrew sent let me say that we
have Andrew Santino everybody he is he
has a special out on Showtime
he also has a TV show up now called I'm
dying up here with Eric Griffin the flat
black we've had on the show an alle
mattress and bean bean we had been being
on the show too al Madrigal and I know
you don't like when I get racial so I at
that or what what I just said being
being and I don't know you can say bean
bean is that black and we have the lead
you the lead in the show well there's
many it's an ensemble who's number one
in the call sheet that little icily hope
yeah yeah yeah no girl that won an Oscar
alright relax well you asked fighter or
that the fighters like the mom yeah yeah
mom she's amazing who's okay who what
number are you on the call [ __ ] when you
see it I'm not gonna tell you
- oh he's do you have to be - no top
five mmhmm yeah is Eric below you though
he's so big I don't know where he bill
board in on New York with it just him on
it one of them it's the whole building I
know I said no you are they see this guy
on the thing I'm dying up here it looks
like a PSA for diabetes so man he didn't
text me back yeah he looks awful on that
[ __ ] building IV I would get in a car
accident with that big head ugly guy
dude one of the ugliest that
yeah yeah sweet sweet we love the very
talented guy he's the best but let me
ask you something he's not a model model
he could be like the before picture
right no you know what yeah I love Grif
so much ooh but Grif is the funniest guy
but like he's like not if you don't know
Erik Griffin look him up he's not shy
about his food addiction yeah and on set
he made this like kind of like heartfelt
promised me that he wouldn't eat a
doughnut and I should restrict him from
eating donuts yeah but I would see him
like go buy the donuts I have like a
conversation with them oh no that's so
funny he'd be standing there like you
know so at the end of the season he was
like I'm at my doughnut day and I have a
stream of you know photo burst photos
yeah of him eating tons
I mean doughnuts don't he's so talented
I know I said all those things it's
truth but it's fine